I found out several days ago that you
were in Mexico City when the earthquake
hit see I were there can you tell us
from your perspective you know what
happened what did it feel like where
were you by the way in Mexico City I was
doing a photo shoot for a theatre play
I'm about to open their promotion and
suddenly everything started moving I was
there in 85 when we had a gigantic
earthquake where the damage and and the
destruction was huge so I thought I I
had some experience you know and I was
like coming out working with everyone
telling jokes to light it up the moment
you were trying you were you trying to
be funny and like during that moment
that's what you have to do because
there's nothing there's no way to stop
it you just have to go to a safe place
and then try to get distracted and and
and not worry and not panic you know
because that's when accidents happen but
suddenly the the earthquake ended and
and I heard something I've never heard
before you know it was like just like
and then we realized damn what was that
and he was so scary and and devastating
and and we run out and there was a
building that fell like half a block
away from where we were completely
collapsed yeah is seven seven story
building and and and a gigantic cloud of
dust in front of us you know destruction
and he was it was horrible to think
about the people that got a chance to
get out and suddenly are seeing
everything they have you know just
disappear in a second and those who are
trapped in there you know you start
thinking about them and and and this is
yeah is it's a it's a horrible
experience I think gets me very
effective but but the the beautiful
thing is you would imagine people would
be running away from this cloud you know
mm-hmm but he was the opposite you know
everyone running towards the cloud
trying to get there to save someone to
save a dog to try to see if there was
anything you could do to help those that
that were there you know and and that's
a beautiful thing I mean it happens in
the country it's such a corrupted
country like ours
when we're you know you know the
government is not gonna get there the
help won't get there it has to be you
you know it has to be citizens reacting
and and that's what I've been witnessing
in my con
which is a lovely thing everyone is
helping everyone has solidarity everyone
is caring about each other about their
neighbors you know and it's it's the
Mexico I feel proud of being part of you
know is the Mexico I belong to is that
that love that that energy of love yeah
of compassionate I would say you know I
brought some pictures you want to walk
these 3ds because I haven't yeah yet
yeah well that's that's just to show you
the kind of destruction that happened in
my country you know that there's a there
was there was a matching building next
to that one and and it's down you know
you can imagine how many people live
there and we have another here I having
and this is what I'm telling you about
the people you know like that man was
found by experts but then he could not
be out of that building unless there was
those hundred people helping you know
using their hands and giving everything
you know that's a beautiful photograph
and then there's beautiful stories like
this one you know this is a masseuse
that decided to go with her chair I
would have a place where they're
rescuing people this man probably has
been working for hours and she's like
you come I'll give you a massage for
free and and I just thought it was a
beautiful thing none of this surprises
me that we spent time in Mexico and none
of this surprised me that people are
there such a strong people and such a
caring loving people I can just I can I
can imagine everyone coming together in
this situation definitely yeah and I'm
gonna show you a true hero yeah this one
is called Frida and she found already 52
people alive oh my god that have been
rescued you know there's like all
artists started doing paintings and
stuff with her because yeah we put
together in Mexico a grassroots civil
effort of to bring help to people so we
we it's called Lago Tanganyika sent I
see it and we've been receiving stuff
that we distribute then to the people
that really need it again in a country
like ours it's ours that have to do
everything this is important because a
lot of people wondered you know how can
they donate to help situation in Mexico
your concern and your friends concerns
have been if it goes to the government
we're not sure if it's gonna be used
most efficiently so you guys are sure by
the way you're a certain they'll be used
inefficiently I don't like this country
where we trust our government so try
going one knee or there's time for that
yeah I don't want to be kicked out of
your shoulder yeah I don't worry we're
[Applause]
people tuning in right now think you're
proposing to me that's the guild that
really fast yeah I want to make sure we
put up this site because this is
important this is a donate amazed calm
slash mehico and we're gonna keep that
up we're gonna take a break but we're
gonna keep this up the entire time that
I continue talking to Diego may I just
say something very quick about this yeah
this is an effort because we were
getting tons of messages from people out
of Mexico saying how can we help
Mexicans or people that have you know
loved relations with Mexico Mexicans and
they were like how can we help and Gael
Garcia Bernal my friend and yes yes I
know he's handsome
anyway we created this platform to raise
money out of Mexico it's very simple you
just need a credit card or PayPal or
whatever it everything will be helped
you know whatever you can donate is good
and if you can share these with as many
people as you can we are gonna make sure
these help gets to the people we're
gonna be behind every decision we're
gonna put together a team of people that
is gonna decide which organizations and
which social efforts we have to support
because this is not a thing that ends in
a week or in two or in three there's
still buildings in Mexico that haven't
been rebuilt from the earthquake in 85
you know this is years and and we need
your help
we need a lot of money
and and we we hope you can you can
donate and be part of this beautiful
effort to give to give love to those who
today lost everything you know
you